[Musique]
120 millions de livres de pommes de
terre sortent de chez patate de le bec
tous les ans la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
a forcer l'automatisation de l'empactage
des 2016 au coup de 12 millions de
dollars depuis 2 ans Hugo baisse tout
s'est tourné vers l'intelligence
artificielle pour trier ses pommes de
terre certainement en vie si on avait
pas fait à modernisation en 2016 et si
on n'avait pas
intégré des travailleurs étrangers on
serait plus en affaires et maintenant si
on n'aurait pas intégré cette
technologie là où effectivement on
serait beaucoup plus en difficulté
présentement dans le recrutement de
notre main d'oeuvre cette technologie
c'est une série de caméras qui détecte
les imperfections grâce à une banque de
30 000 photos de pommes de terre elles
sont ensuite triées grâce aux
algorithmes dans une douzaine de
catégories selon leurs qualités et leurs
défauts lorsque les patates passent la
machine apprend des photos
l'intelligence artificielle a néanmoins
des 30 ans d'expérience de Nathalie
Frenette elle enseigne aux algorithmes
de nouveaux défauts plus spécifiques
pour un client plus exigeants
lesquels il faut être capable de séparer
selon si ça va transformation ça va pour
un client qui est Sauveur le tri
automatique affiche maintenant un taux
de réussite de 70 % mais nécessite
toujours une supervision humaine il
faudra attendre quelques années avant
d'atteindre l'objectif de 95% de succès
on vise en phase un de passer à un
trieur par ta batterie par corps de
travail et avec le temps j'assume qu'on
va réussir à éliminer totalement les
clients les gens avaient peur la
première question qui était sur toutes
les lèvres il n'est pas si longtemps
c'est la technologie va-t-elle voler mon
emploi aujourd'hui on est plus le pantou
l'entreprise d'automatisation derrière
le projet de patate Dolbec voit dans
l'agroalimentaire un marché prometteur
la main d'oeuvre non seulement rare
représente aussi la dépense la plus
élevée des maraîchers un secteur selon
une Falls qui accuse un retard
technologique les seuls qui dans 5
survivorantes et c'est soit des
entreprises qui renforcement beaucoup
innover ou malheureusement peut-être
qu'ils ont été achetés par des
entreprises étrangères qui auront rentré
des nouvelles technologies c'est
difficile de
faire et de trouver les projets
maintenant qui vont amener notre
compétitivité dans 5 à 6 ans il faut
déjà travailler sur ces projets là
encore coûteuse l'intelligence
artificielle semble nécessaire pour
affronter la concurrence de demain même
pour les aliments les plus anodins ici
Jean-Philippe piouze Radio-Canada stubal